los mexicanos sufren las consecuencias
de la inflación el país Azteca cerró el
mes de septiembre con una inflación del
8.70%. la más alta de los últimos 22
años que afecta directamente a sus
ciudadanos uno de los productos en los
que más se refleja la situación es en
las famosas tortillas para hacer tacos
ya que la producción del maíz es cada
vez más costosa antes podías comprar
tortilla muy fácilmente y ahora el
precio pues subió casi el doble en el
último año entonces creo que eso sí pasa
a afectar a cualquier economía hay
muchos productores que siembran que no
ven reflejadas o ganancia en la
inversión que hacen al producto y
entonces dicen Pues mejor lo vendo no
según el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador y los pronósticos del Gobierno
Federal la inflación llegó a su pico
máximo y los próximos meses irá a la
Baja como sucedió de agosto a septiembre
registrando una reducción del 0.62%
pero mientras tanto los mexicanos luchan
por Buscar su estabilidad económica como
esta mujer que tiene un puesto de
comidas en un mercado de la Ciudad de
México y asegura que su negocio está al
borde del colapso los productos están
también nuestra ganancia no es este
así que porque no podemos nosotros
también subir tanto los precios al
cliente ante la gente no preguntaba por
los precios el gobierno ha anunciado
medidas económicas para hacer frente a
la inflación y a pesar del aumento del
costo de vida la economía de México ha
mejorado durante el 2022 el pronóstico
oficial estima terminar el año con una
tasa de crecimiento del
2.4%. y una tasa de desempleo del 3.5%